bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
chios que tout de suite le sommaire de
ce mercredi 18 mai marie-laure reste
ignares directrice du rayonnement
culturel à saint quentin en yvelines et
en plateau accompagné des artistes en
résidence benoît est beau il nous
présente la programmation spéciale du
samedi 21 mai de 20h à minuit pour la
nuit des musées sur saint quentin en
yvelines
françoise gaulier organisatrice du
festival romantique de buc et
jean-pierre salmona pianiste nous
rejoindront dans quelques instants pour
nous parler de la 5e édition du festival
romantique de buc et de sa programmation
pour le dimanche 22 mai et nous
conclurons cette émission avec une
séquence insolite et xav de master et
trois membres de l'équipe hypnotisme
nous inviteront à découvrir le monde de
l'hypnose avec leur spectacle voyage
dans ton intention au cirano de
versailles le 27 mai prochain et on
démarre cette émission avec vous
marie-laure reste ignore bonsoir vous
êtes la directrice donc du rayonnement
culturel sur saint quentin en yvelines
et vous êtes venu accompagné de benoit
et beaux artistes visuels en résidence
toute l'année vous est d'ailleurs venu
accompagné de vos masques on en parlera
un petit peu plus tard alors samedi soir
aura lieu la 12e édition de la nuit des
musées partout en france et sur saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est rien ça exactement donc la nuit
des musées comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
une nuit où les musées sont ouverts
donc vous pouvez y aller et c'est
gratuit pour tout le monde donc l'entrée
est libre
et tous les ans à saint quentin en
yvelines dans le cadre du budget de la
ville
on offre une programmation tout à fait
spécifique particulière et cette année
est encore plus particulière que les
autres années puisque certains plus
constaté le musée est pour l'instant
fermé au public puisqu'il va déménager
il va aller ailleurs il va se réinventer
et donc on organise une nuit des musées
et sous l'égide imaginons un musée à
saint quentin en yvelines
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un musée à saint
quentin en yvelines d'abord certains
d'entre vous le connaissent pas
certainement
et qu'est ce que c'est que ce musée donc
ce musée il s'appuie sur deux choses la
première c'est le label ville d'art et
d'histoire depuis 2006 saint quentin en
yvelines a eu le label ville d'art et
d'histoire pour son patrimoine
contemporain
donc nous on est chargé de mettre en
valeur au musée ce patrimoine et la
deuxième chose qui est au moins aussi
importante c'est que mu et s'attache aux
modes de vie contemporains
c'est à dire que depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale on a vu nos modes de vie
changer avec l'exode rural par exemple
avec l'arrivée ville l'urbanisation à
tout crin et on a collecté depuis un
certain nombre d'années donc depuis
quasiment 40 ans des traces de cette
urbanisation de façon à les laisser à
nos à nos successeurs ont fait en fait
une sorte d'archéologie du contemporain
de façon à ce que nos successeurs arrête
de mettre des idées complètement
farfelues sur des objets qui nous sont
absolument quotidien je prends l'exemple
par exemple de cette fameuse essoreuse à
salade ou sauver cette espèce de deux
choses orange que vous tournez
exactement eh bien le musée de la danse
les collections alors vous allez me dire
mais qu'est ce que fait une essoreuse à
salade dans ses collections
moi je vais vous expliquer parce
qu'effectivement quand les populations
ont déménagé au moment d exode rural ils
sont venus
donc c'était vraiment dans les années 50
60 ils sont arrivés en ville mais avant
il était habitué à prendre savez le
fameux panier à salade en métal et puis
avec des grands moulinets de bras
il a les laisserai dans leur jardin mais
croyez moi dans deux pièces cuisine ou
trois pièces cuisine c'est plus possible
donc il a fallu inventer quelque chose
de nouveau des objets nouveaux et toute
la vie que nous avons aujourd'hui tous
nos modes de vie sont axées sur cette
évolution de notre façon de vivre et
donc la fameuse essoreuse à salade
permet aujourd'hui dans de petites
cuisines des souris sans faire de goût
de partout notre fameuse salade et voilà
ce que nous avons à l'oeil et collecté
dans ce lieu de mémoire dont qui est le
musée de la ville alors au musée de la
ville du coup qui va rouvrir ses portes
samedi soir pour présenter une
exposition imagine ont amusé imaginons
une zone qui va expliquer ce que nous
avons dans nos collections et les
collections mode de vie avec la fameuse
essoreuse à salade je vous promets cali
sera et tout ce qui traite de notre
patrimoine
leur public puisque nous sommes un des
lieux emblématiques d'art public en île
de france a envoyé le plus d'oeuvres
d'art public
l' architecture et donc vous allez voir
ce que c'est que le patrimoine saint
quentinois destiné à tous les saint
quentinois et vous allez peut-être
découvrir sur moi donc cette exposition
elle va courir jusqu'au 2 juillet
prochain exactement sera donc présenté
au public mais également 7
un événement en partenariat avec des
artistes en résidence
exactement on a appelé cette exposition
imaginons un musée leur nom l'a imaginée
comme on le fait en tant que
scientifique du musée que conservateur
et c'est fabien de bien sérieux assez
amusant quand même mais on a convoqué
des artistes et on leur a demandé de
venir dialoguer avec un musée dans ce
que c'était que imaginer un musée donc
on a un artiste qui s'appelle florence
rochelle et qui a imaginé alors il n'est
pas en tête et aujourd'hui mais florent
imaginer une machine à rêves
vous rentrez vos rêves dedans et il va
les mettre en images grâce aux
collections du musée donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez innovant même de très
innovant un ces deux routes très axiale
it
donc venez voir tester la machine à
rêves vous rentrez vos rêves et vous
venir en image derrière grâce aux objets
du musée mais on n'a pas seulement fait
rentrer chez elle on a aussi nos deux
autres artistes qui sont là benoît et
bois alors vous c'est plutôt un studio
photographique vous allez animer lors de
ce temps fort oui on a décidé de faire
participer le public amusé c'est aussi
son public
on va on a décidé de créer une sorte de
banque de dos
de photographique avec tous les gens qui
viendront se faire photographier dans
notre studio pour la nuit des musées
vous avez occupé de mon masque parce que
ces masques seront portés par le plus
beaucoup et ça sera ce seront des photos
avec masques puisque ce qui nous
permettra aussi de mettre en ligne où
les gens de ne pas être reconnu ce qui
simplifie pas mal de choses ce qui ce
qui sont timides pour être pour en être
photographiée sans problème mes enfants
aussi ont vraiment oui ouvert à tous
types de publics alors vous avez
l'habitude justement de travailler avec
le public parce que vous étiez donc
artiste en résidence à la commanderie
des templiers toute l'année et vous avez
organisé également différentes
masterclass avec l'école d'arts
plastiques d'elancourt il ya une
exposition qui proposait justement une
forme de restitution de ces masters
classes fêtes en partenariat avec les
élèves alors toujours ce travail du
numérique et de la peinture qui est
présentée jusqu'au 22 mai prochain et on
écoute laurent majorie qui nous en parle
les travaux qui sont réalisés par les
enfants sont basés sur les usages du
numérique c'est à dire à la fois
l'utilisation bien entendu de documents
qui leur appartiennent c'est à dire des
photographies familiales des
photographies qu'ils ont pris eux mêmes
ou des éléments graphiques ils sont
allés récupérer sur internet mails
usages du numérique leur a permis en
intégrant l'ensemble des soit de ces
photographies dans des environnements
urbains également pris en photo ou
récupérées sur internet de réaliser
comme le fond benoît est beau des
oeuvres originales qui intègrent leur
univers personnel dans un univers
fantasmé d'ordre urbain donc cette
exposition complètement dissocié de la
nuit des musées elle est présentée à la
ferme du mousseau sur elle en cours
jusqu'au 22 mai et donc au musée de la
ville
ouverture à partir de 18 heures cette
ouverture à partir de 18 heures jusqu'à
22 heures donc pour la nuit des musées
musée de la ville l'exposition sera
présentée
imaginons un musée avec une activité
parallèle la machine à rêves de flore
entre shell et le studio photographique
de benoît est beau merci à vous trois
d'être venu en plateau et de nous avoir
fait partager la programmation de cette
douzième nuit d
sur saint quentin en yvelines la
maréchalerie de versailles centre d'art
contemporain sera également ouverte pour
cette nuit des musées jusqu'à 22h et
présente l'exposition lacunes féconde de
marc johnson 24 tonnes de terre et de
graminées sauvages ont envahi la
maréchalerie de versailles une sculpture
vivante
intitulé lacunes féconde réalisée par
l'artiste plasticien et architecte marc
johnson
diplômé des beaux-arts de paris et de
l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé de paris malaquais
l'artiste propose une approche à la fois
sensible et abstraite des enjeux
bioéthiques
ici on est dans une problématique qui
ouvre à une certaine transversalité des
disciplines c'est un artiste qui
croisent dans ce projet en particulier
l'armée aussi l'archéologie la génétique
c'est cela aussi qui était intéressant
et singulier de sa part c'était de
tenter de créer à travers le dispositif
dans lequel on circule quitter ce
paysage donc végétalisée revégétaliser
où la nature reprend ses droits
c'était vraiment de traiter de ces
questions transversales l'oeuvre vivante
vient confronté l'art ancestral de
l'archéologie au progrès scientifique
pour l'artiste les principales
évolutions du 21e siècle en
nanotechnologies biotechnologies
sciences du cerveau et intelligence
artificielle viendront transformer
demain l'industrie la médecine et les
neurosciences
une intelligence artificielle
accompagnent d'ailleurs le visiteur dans
le dispositif en déclamant un texte
autour de l'avenir de l'activité humaine
il ya un an de travail avec institut
national de recherches archéologiques
préventives
il s'agit de comprendre comment les
technologies aujourd'hui notamment
l'apport de la génétique en archéologie
pas pouvoir transformer le vivant et
pose des questions fondamentales pour
nous aujourd'hui comme l'interaction des
technologies avec notre corps propre les
neurosciences et donc des questions
philosophiques comme le mouvement
culturel
notamment le transit manistes le post
sionisme les études de marc johnson sur
le sujet ont amené à l'édition prochaine
d'un livre sur la bioéthique et pour les
visiteurs désireux de s'approprier ce
sujet un questionnaire de vingt-et-une
question est distribuée pour prolonger
la réflexion philosophique et
scientifique
et voici maintenant pour continuer sur
la thématique de la nuit des musées un
agenda spéciale nuit des musées pour
samedi soir alors vous pourrez vous
rendre au musée de la toile de jouy à
jouy en josas pour un atelier
d'initiation à la teinture de 18 à 23
heures et vous pourrez ainsi profiter de
l'exposition en cours peindre hoeness
d'atteindre le château de versailles
sera également ouvert pour l'occasion et
invite à découvrir sa nouvelle galerie
des carences de 19h à 1h du matin ainsi
que son académie équestre national
différentes animations sont proposées au
musée promenade de marly le relou sienne
de 20 heures à 23 heures 30 lectures
théâtralisées musique projections et
ateliers pour les enfants
une soirée dédiée à don quichotte le
musée lambinet également à versailles
ouvrira ses portes pour vous offrir une
visite de la nouvelle exposition sur
julia barthet la divine une comédienne
de la belle époque lecture musique et
spectacles de danse au programme
et enfin le musée national de port royal
des champs sera également ouvert et
proposera une visite animée de
l'exposition de rosa bonheur leur
dernière exposition ainsi qu'une
exposition de sculpture et modelage
réalisés par les élèves du cours de
poterie présenté dans les granges de
port royal et entre le musée et
l'artiste il n'y a qu'un pas comme nous
le montre le couple d'artistes amateurs
barbier après une formation en dessin et
peinture en 2001 de quatre ans et une
production artistique régulière en
atelier
le couple expose ses oeuvres à la maison
félix de montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au
22 mai nous avons suivi les qu ensemble
tous les 2 mois puis mon niveau
et puis à la maison on ne vend pas
beaucoup de temps c'est plutôt à
l'atelier nous faisons ensemble si
j'aime tous les
la beauté de paysages même le visage des
gens donc tous vos dons j'ai lutté ces
témoins s'amincit bessat envie de
reproduire les tables vous moi je
représente souvent des tableaux de
maîtres ou suivant les torts postales
des photos en pensant je fais pas
vraiment d'un création c'est surtout la
copine et après avoir profité le samedi
soir de la 12e édition de la nuit des
musées
je vous convie le dimanche 22 mai à la
cinquième édition du festival romantique
de buc ça aura lieu à partir de 10
heures 30 au château de buc alors pour
en parler avec moi françoise brié vous
êtes l'organisatrice du festival et
jean-pierre salmona vous êtes pianiste
françoise pourquoi avoir initié ce
festival romantique sur bucs
alors il y a dix ans nous avons créé une
association musicale domicile acquis
dont l'objectif principal est de donner
des cours de musique à domicile
nous souhaitions également proposer des
concerts pour que les adhérents puissent
se rencontrer et découvrir la musique et
en 2010 est née l'idée de faire plus
qu'un concert mais une journée complète
de concerts donc en 2010 c'était le
bicentenaire de la naissance de chopin
et puis nous avions la possibilité
d'avoir ce théâtre d'avoir ce com
théâtre finalement le thé le château de
buc quitte un vrai lieu romantique alors
jean-pierre sa monnaie qu'est ce qui
caractérise la musique romantique
alors la musique romantique en fait
c'est la musique des deux derniers tiers
du 19e siècle
c'est une musique qui caractérise et
finalement par là la sorte il l'évasion
des formes et de la rigueur expressive
de l'époque des lumières
donc il s'agit pour les compositeurs
maintenant d'exprimer à la suite du jeu
tourne drogue du xviiie siècle qui
signifie de tempête et passion un
mouvement né en allemagne dans la
deuxième partie xviiie siècle il s'agit
pour les compositeurs dont d'exprimer
des émotions beaucoup plus personnel que
par les compositeurs précédent et sas
illustre de façon différente suivant les
lieux elle est née principalement en
europe
mais suivant les
mieux elle s'illustre de façon
différente et c'est pourquoi on a choisi
en fait trois lieux un peu phare du
romantisme à célébrer dans trois
concerts bourse et ce à la thématique
c'est au tour d'un voyage de l'europe
des lieux phares haut lieu culturel pour
cette musique romantique donc vous
l'avez dit vienne saint pétersbourg et
paraît alors comment est ce que vous
avez pensé
la programmation autour de ces trois
lieux une fois que les lieux sont
définis la programmation on s'impose un
peu d'elle-même
c'est à dire que viennent on pense
naturellement à beethoven qui est la
charnière entre la période classique et
la période romantique et puis si on a
pensé à beethoven on pense assez
facilement abrams puisque onze bureaux
considéré que brahms était le successeur
de beethoven
alors justement c'est vrai c'est écouter
un extrait de brad
donc là on est plus du côté de vienne
on va partir maintenant du côté de saint
pétersbourg avec rachmaninoff leur
rakhmaninov du romantisme disons que
c'est un compositeur romantique qui
composent à la toute fin du 19e siècle
et au début du 20e siècle
puisqu'en fait la vie de compositeurs de
rachmaninoff se passe en russie et que
sa vie de pianistes se passe aux états
unis puisqu'il a émigré après la
révolution et rachmaninoff c'est
vraiment à la fois pour le pianiste est
pour l'auditeur c'est vraiment
l'archétype de du romantisme russe quoi
delà de cette espèce d'expression
extraordinaire qui conquiert absolument
tous les auditeurs et puis dans saint
pétersbourg
on déborde sur la sortie du romantisme
puisque on fait jouer côte à côte un
trio de rachmaninoff trio élégiaque
composé j'ai eu le premier composé juste
avant la mort de tchaïkovski une sorte
d'hommage 2 de rachmaninov à son aîné
et puis alors on fait jouer à trop de
choses peuvent l'acheter presse
à
et
on
en
puis on pourra retrouver également du
chopin du beethoven alors jean-pierre
salmona quels sont les types de
musiciens c'est sûr il ya aussi bien sûr
du musicien professionnel que des grands
amateurs
oui alors d'abord le premier concert
mettra en scène essentiellement des
grands amateurs donc des pianistes qui
en fait la manière en prime est sorti au
concours des grands amateurs de piano
sortante conservatoires nationaux de
région et puis un violoniste aussi un
train très bon violoniste amateur bien
des cordes du piano
qu'est ce qui fait la spécificité du
festival françoise alors la spécificité
du festival c'est l'unité dans le
programme déjà ce n'est pas une
succession de concerts mais c'est une il
y à une unité dans la journée ce qui
fait sa spécificité un sony le lieu
insolite le château bien sûr c'est
toujours un plaisir de se retrouver ce
sont des temps de rencontres aussi
puisque nous souhaitons à nos affaires
on y tient oui puisque on souhaite que
les spectateurs les partenaires du
projet et les musiciens puissent avoir
des moments pour se rencontrer pour que
ça reste un moment de partage
voilà merci à vous deux d'être venu nous
présenter donc la cinquième édition du
festival romantique de but qui se
déroulera le dimanche 22 mai à partir de
10 heures 30 au château de buc et sans
transition voici maintenant votre
rubrique septième art vos réactions sur
les nouveautés à la fiche de cette
semaine tout de suite alors c'est un
très très bonne bd heures
nous devons superbe c'est vraiment bien
au moins fait aimer parce que brosse et
d'un film qui lance un message quand
même sur le monde de des traders de la
finance de tout ce qui se passe qu'on ne
sait pas quoi
oui oui ça m'a bien plu c
il ya du suspense
c'est très bien interprété évidemment
puisqu'il ya george clooney julia
roberts
voilà c'est un bon film pour moi c'est
complètement déjanté mais c'est super
drôle et très très bien tourner les
comédiens sont excellents et cette
semaine pour le coup de coeur de
professionnels c'est lui beaucoup ont dû
signer cette d'elancourt alors le coup
de coeur du ciné cette semaine c'est un
un petit fier votre lit mais que j'aime
pas employer cette expression quand je
dis petit film c'est parce qu'il est
sorti sur trop peu d'écrans avance ans
s'est mariée et naufragés
c'est un film de sébastien joly
begbeider avec pierre rochefort ville
vimala pons qu'on inflige à dents comme
un avion de bruno podalydès
et puis eric cantona donc c'est une
histoire un peu légères un peu loufoque
l'histoire d'un homme joué par rochefort
qui rencontre ce docu ton amoureux fou
de cette jeune femme qui est selon son
ex jouer avec suavité par eric cantona
qui veut prendre de l'épaisseur de rôle
en rôle est dangereux et jugés dangereux
j'en dis pas plus c'est une comédie
douce ni faute qui nous emmène sur l'île
de groix donc on voyage on se balade un
petit peu en france
c'est très très bien interprété c'est
très sympa et c'est à découvrir dans les
salles cette semaine que sera l'issue de
ce voyage
et avant de refermer ce magazine je vous
convie vendredi 27 mai 20 heures au
cirano de versailles à un spectacle
insolite un spectacle d'hypnose intitulé
voyage dans son inconscient pour en
parler avec moi xav master edouard
cédric et sébastien je vous propose de
regarder tout de suite un extrait du
spectacle
alors voyage dans son inconscient
c'est donc un spectacle d'hypnose
réalisé par votre collectif un collectif
de sept hypnotiseur vous êtes tous
hypnotiseur xavier oui on est un groupe
de sept hypnotiseur donc on est quatre
spécialisé dans le spectacle il ya trois
personnes qui sont spécialisés dans la
bienveillance thérapie et qui assure la
sécurité le jour du spectacle
c'est particulièrement important dans
l'aspect sécuritaire sur ce type de
spectacle alors nous c'est vraiment là
dessus qu'on met l'accent c'est à dire
que on peut faire le show et on sait
qu'on a des personnes qui sont
spécialisés là dedans dans le spectacle
pour pouvoir réveiller tout le monde des
maîtres les gens sécurité donc ça pour
le public c'est c'est assez rassurant
ses buts web c'est parce que drake
l'hypnose ont souvent on peut rentrer en
transe il peut y avoir des effets
secondaires des conséquences dont vous
êtes vraiment là pour encadrer ce à ce
que vous pourriez sébastien nous
organiser le nous expliquer l'origine du
spectacle vous avez démarré par le
street hypnos voilà donc on a commencé
dans la rue on était tous les trois dans
un premier temps et un adjoint au maire
de la ville on habite vous a demandé de
créer un spectacle nous a repérés on a
dit on a relevé le défi on a monté un
spectacle c'est comme ça qu'on a
récupéré cédric et les trois autres
personnes pour faire ce spectacle qui
s'est rempli très très rapidement fait
on a été assez surpris du de
l'enthousiasmé des gens pour les
spectacle d'hypnose
c'est vrai que ça fait quelques années
que vraiment on met les pneus en avant
aussi bien pour ses vertus
thérapeutiques que pour ses vertus plus
spectaculaires alors cédric justement
expliquez nous comment est-ce que ça se
passe sur scène c'est vraiment un
spectacle de deux heures en
l'interaction complète avec le public
c'est ça c'est vraiment un spectacle où
le public peut monter sur scène donc on
va faire quelques tests de la ces petits
vitae ou après on amène les personnes
qui sont réceptives à monter sur scène
ont lésé convient avec xavier il ya
edwards qui est derrière sur scène pour
la sécurité de justement ces personnes
qui sont sur scène ensuite on a vraiment
trois hypnotiseur dans la salle qu'on
appelle les anges gardiens un peu
pour la sécurité dans la salle et
derrière sébastien et moi on est en
régie en technique et de temps en temps
se permet un peu de sortir et justement
s'il ya vraiment besoin dans la salle
c'est pour ça qu'on est aussi que
naughty dog donc les gens sur scène
participent au spectacle mais également
les gens dans la salle c'est ça c'est
vraiment une interaction entre ce qui se
passe sur scène et dans la salle à tout
moment en fait on des personnes de la
salle peuvent interagir sur le spectacle
donc on a vraiment le fil conducteur
mais de temps en temps ça nous arrive un
peu d'en sortir et de jouer un peu avec
le public sébastien le rôle du son et de
la lumière sur ce type de spectacle il
est important très important en fait on
a utilisé des musiques hypnotiques la
lumière et hypnotique notre but c'était
vraiment de créer un spectacle c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs qu'on ait cette
hypothèse heures et qu'on sait avec
cédric mis à la régie on ne retrouve
prendre n'importe quel régisseur mais on
a voulu vraiment il participe et
justement pour mettre toute la salle
dans une ambiance hypnotique edward
c'est vrai que nous parlait justement du
fait que dans le public y avait des
personnes plus ou moins réceptive à
l'épineuse qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'un
individu va être plus ou moins sensibles
à ça alors ça va être une question de
lâcher prise ne plus la personne se
laissera aller et sera détendue et plus
elle pourra imaginer ce qu'on va lui
proposer et plus elle pourra partir en
état de transe dans un état où elle sera
consciente de vraiment tout ce qui se
passe autour d'elle mais qu'israël sera
vraiment détendue relâché à vivre des
effets assez cool vous aviez c'est
ouvert à tout type de public les enfants
peuvent participer ou pas alors on
déconseille un petit peu aux enfants de
moins de 10 ans pas que ce soit
dangereux mais simplement que les gens
ont besoin de se concentrer et donc on
invite les gens à venir à partir de 10
ans si les enfants 8 ans ils peuvent
tenir et se tenir calmement y'a pas de
soucis pour venir au spectacle c'est je
le disais c'est relativement
spectaculaire phare est assez
impressionnant alors c'est
impressionnant et par rapport aux
enfants on voit souvent des parents ou
leurs amis qui sont en transe sur la
scène et ça peu un petit peu
choquer les enfants quand ils ont quatre
ans 50 voir leurs parents dans cet état
là donc pour que les parents puissent se
laisse aller le mieux possible les
restes à la maison et on peut faire un
spectacle avec tout le monde donc pour
savoir si vous êtes plus ou moins
sensibles à l'hypnose je vous convie le
vendredi 27 mai au cinéma cyrano de
versailles pour venir assister au
spectacle voyage dans son inconscient
avec le collectif hic nothing merci
messieurs d'être venu en plateau nous
présenter ce spectacle et c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission culturelle vous
pourrez la voir et la revoir sur notre
site internet pour ma part je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée